I have a daughter who's three and by the
time she's having kids I want the world
to be completely different for her so
should we go let's go
so many moms go through a postnatal mood
or anxiety disorder alone and don't know
where to turn and don't know where to
look for help and they know something's
wrong but they they just lack the
resources
when you're going through postpartum
depression it's one of the most
isolating experiences that you can have
and I think knowing that other people
are going through it if you is so
incredibly important to being able to
just keep breathing and get out of that
every day it wasn't until I started
talking about it and just having people
I barely knew say oh yeah I had that and
then being able to talk that I just
realized I wasn't crazy that I hadn't
done anything wrong unless you've walked
through that darkness you just don't get
it
this is so common they say one in seven
moms go through this but you wouldn't
know it and we talk about motherhood and
giving birth as if it's this wonderful
joyous thing and it is but they could be
very very difficult for a lot of moms my
recovery didn't start until I met other
moms who were going through and had been
through the same experience as me so
every year this is a great opportunity
for other moms to come to a place where
they're going to find their community
and have that moment of recovery that I
was so lucky to have it's worth it to
get through it and connect with other
people there's nothing more important
than knowing that you are not the only
person going service
it takes a team we need every mother who
has ever had maternal mental illness and
every person who has ever loved someone
with a maternal mental illness to join
our team if we don't all come together
we'll never be able to get to the day
when every mom knows what's wrong knows
where to go gets help quickly and
recovers quickly if you are listening to
this right now and you are a mom who is
struggling please know that you are
loved and understood we know how you
feel we know all the doubts that you
have about yourself we know what it's
like to feel like you are a failure as a
mother worried that you'll never get
better we're also fortunate to have come
out on the other side so we know that
you can and will get through this and we
want you to know we will be here for you
all along the way
Oh